Looking for and successfully finding love is not easy for most people. Online dating has made it a little easier, but knowing what to look for in a partner is something many people still struggle with in the modern dating world. In this episode, we talk with psychologist Tai Tishiro, who gives advice and tips on how to use psychological science to find lasting love, showing us that using our heads and not just our hearts can lead to our happily ever after. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is soon. Speaking of psychology. Psychologist Ty Tishiro is an author and researcher who studies the psychology of relationships. Why some relationships last and others don't.
对大多数人来说，寻找并成功获得爱情并非易事。在线约会虽然让这件事变得容易了一些，但在现代约会世界中，很多人仍然在苦恼于该如何寻找合适的伴侣。在本期节目中，我们采访了心理学家泰·田代（Ty Tashiro），他提供了如何利用心理科学寻找持久爱情的建议和技巧，向我们展示了运用理智而非仅仅依靠情感，也能通往幸福的结局。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这是《谈谈心理学》。心理学家泰·田代是一位研究人际关系心理学的作家和研究员，他研究为什么有些关系能长久，而有些则不能。
His work has been published in top-tier academic journals, including the American Psychological Association's flagship journal American Psychologist. He is also author of the book, The Science of Happily Ever After. Welcome, Dr. Tishiro. Thanks for having me. We're often told to follow our hearts when we're looking for love. Is that really the best advice, or is there a better way? way to go about it. Well, that's a great question. I don't think there's anything wrong with following
他的研究成果发表在顶级学术期刊上，包括美国心理学会的旗舰期刊《美国心理学家》。他也是《幸福的科学》（The Science of Happily Ever After）一书的作者。欢迎您，田代博士。谢谢邀请。当我们寻找爱情时，常被告知要追随内心。这真的是最好的建议吗？还是有更好的方法？嗯，这是个好问题。我不认为追随内心有什么错。
your heart. Love's primarily an emotional thing, and I think we can overthink it if we're not careful, so we don't want to kill the romance or kill the heart part of it with the head. But I do think that people could probably benefit from using their head just a little bit more when it comes to really one of the most important decisions they'll make, which is who they choose to be with for the rest of their life. Yeah. Can you talk about how their head needs to become involved? in finding the right person? Sure, yeah. Well, I think it's hard to get your head involved
爱情主要是一种情感体验，我认为如果不加小心，我们可能会想得太多，所以我们不希望用理智去扼杀浪漫或情感的部分。但我确实认为，人们在做出人生中最重要的决定之一——即选择与谁共度余生时，如果能多用一点理智，可能会从中受益。是的。你能谈谈在寻找合适的人时，理智应该如何介入吗？当然，可以。嗯，我认为当你和一个新人在一起时，很难保持理智。
when you're with a new person. When we fall in that passionate love, we have the butterflies in the stomach and your head spinning, it's really hard to be rational and measured about things and have good foresight. I think actually in-between relationships
当我们陷入那种热恋时，会有小鹿乱撞的感觉，头脑发昏，很难理性、审慎地看待事物，也很难有长远的眼光。我认为实际上在两段感情之间
is a great time. And there you have these windows of clarity where you can reflect upon what's worked or hasn't worked in previous relationships. And also set some goals or some strategy for what you want to do differently going forward. And that then kind of directs people's attention to traits that might be desirable that they usually don't go for or puts them on alert for traits that are not good for them that they've had in the past.
是一个很好的时机。那时你有清晰的窗口期，可以反思过去感情中哪些是有效的，哪些是无效的。同时，也可以为未来想要做出的改变设定一些目标或策略。这会引导人们关注那些通常不会考虑但可能很理想的特质，或者对过去曾带给自己负面影响的特质保持警惕。
And this sort of leads into what you've talked about, the three wishes within when you're choosing someone to be with. Can you explain what you mean by that? Is there not one perfect person for everyone, that fairy tale romance? Well, it's hard to argue with fate. You never know what the evidence is against it, I guess. But I think there's probably more than one person for people. But a lot of the research shows that people want a lot of things, a lot of ideal traits or characteristics in a partner.
这引出了你所谈到的，在选择伴侣时的“三个愿望”。你能解释一下你的意思吗？难道没有那种童话般的浪漫，即每个人都有一个完美伴侣吗？嗯，很难与命运争辩。我想你永远不知道反对它的证据是什么。但我认为，人们可能不止有一个合适的对象。但许多研究表明，人们想要很多东西，想要伴侣具备很多理想的特质或特征。
And that's great to have high aspirations. But I think that prioritizing the order in which or the importance of these traits would be a wise thing to do. Because there's some studies that find that people wish for everything, and then they end up getting very little of what's actually important to them in a romantic partner. So if people can have their top three prioritized, the good news is they have pretty good odds of getting those three traits in their romantic partner. Can you give us an example of what you're talking about? Sure.
拥有高期望是件好事。但我认为，对这些特质进行优先排序或权衡其重要性会更明智。因为有些研究发现，人们什么都想要，结果却在浪漫伴侣身上得到了很少真正重要的东西。所以，如果人们能将最重要的三个特质排在首位，好消息是，他们很有可能在伴侣身上找到这三个特质。你能举个例子说明一下吗？当然。
Sure. Well, it could be personality characteristics like extroversion or agreeableness. It could be physical characteristics like being hot or being tall. And I'll give you an example of how that might work when you just do the math with it. So let's say there's someone who wants a man who's tall. And to him or her, that's someone who's six-foot or taller. Well, only 20% of men in the United States meet that criteria. So if there are a room of 100 eligible bachelors, that would mean 80 of those men would be disqualified at that point.
当然。嗯，这可以是性格特征，比如外向或随和。也可以是身体特征，比如长得帅或个子高。我来举个例子，当你用数学计算时，它是如何运作的。假设有人想要一个高个子男人。对他或她来说，这意味着身高六英尺或以上。嗯，在美国，只有20%的男性符合这个标准。所以，如果房间里有100个符合条件的单身汉，那就意味着其中80个人在这一点上就被淘汰了。
Now if this person wanted someone, let's say, with a college education, you'd lose about two-thirds of the remaining people. So now you're down really to just about four people after two wishes. So you can see after three wishes for traits, you really eliminate a lot of possibilities. So those are the odds behind why you just can't find the right person. Sure. Yeah, and it happens in real life where online dating is a great example, where people will set certain criteria with the mentality that it's a preference. But actually, you're just completely ruling someone out.
现在，如果这个人还想要一个受过大学教育的人，你就会失去剩下人群中大约三分之二的人。所以，在两个愿望之后，你实际上只剩下大约四个人了。所以你可以看到，在三个特质愿望之后，你确实消除了很多可能性。这就是为什么你找不到合适的人背后的概率问题。当然。是的，这在现实生活中也会发生，在线约会就是一个很好的例子，人们设定某些标准时，心态上觉得这只是偏好。但实际上，你是在完全排除掉某些人。
If you say that I don't want someone of this religious affiliation or this height or whatever else it might be, it actually cuts out a lot of people that might have had traits that you really want it. Do you encourage people to do the online dating, those websites, or, you know, what's your opinion on how those work? Well, I think it's great in the sense that it expands the pool dramatically. And there was just a study that came out last year. It was a really nice study of tens of thousands of singles,
如果你说我不想要某种宗教信仰或某种身高的人，或者其他任何条件，这实际上排除了很多可能具备你真正想要的特质的人。你鼓励人们进行在线约会，使用那些网站吗？或者，你对它们是如何运作的有什么看法？嗯，我认为从扩大选择范围的角度来看，这很棒。去年刚出了一项研究，是对数万名单身人士进行的一项非常好的研究，
seeing how they met their partner and what the long-term outcomes were. And online dating performed just as well as a lot of other traditional ways that we meet people, such as through family or friends or, you know, in-person at school or something like that. Is there a way to do it wrong, I guess, if you're, Like you say, if you're putting in too many requirements, so to speak, into the matching profiles that they have? Sure, I think that would be one way to really narrow your pools and how one of the major advantages of having a lot of people has been taken away from you.
观察他们是如何结识伴侣的，以及长期的结果如何。在线约会的效果与我们结识他人的许多传统方式一样好，比如通过家人或朋友，或者在学校等面对面交流。我想问，如果像你所说的那样，在匹配资料中设置了太多的要求，是不是就做错了？当然，我认为这确实是一种缩小选择范围的方式，原本拥有大量人选的巨大优势就这样被你浪费了。
Online dating is great, too, as far as data collection, because people can actually watch behavior. So instead of just asking on a self-report, what do you want, or who would you choose as a partner? They're able to say, hey, this is what people actually did when they were online. And there was a great thing just came out from OKCupid showing how much of the proportion of time people spent on profile pictures. And how strongly that correlated with people that they messaged. And it was really at a rate that was a little bit disheartening.
在线约会也很棒，因为可以收集数据，人们实际上可以观察行为。所以，与其仅仅通过自我报告来询问你想要什么，或者你会选择谁作为伴侣，他们能够说，嘿，这就是人们在线时实际所做的。OKCupid刚刚发布了一项很棒的研究，显示了人们在个人资料照片上花费的时间比例，以及这与他们发送消息的对象之间的相关性有多强。这个比例确实让人有点沮丧。
What about marriage? And we get away from the dating, we get on, we finally meet someone, we're happy. How can psychological research help determine what makes a lasting happy marriage? Not just a lasting marriage, a happy marriage. Happily and the ever after both. Right, exactly. Well, there's a lot of good data now, and we're lucky that there's these prospective studies that catch people before they ever met their partner sometimes, sometimes when they're dating, or sometimes when they're newlyweds, and follow them for seven, 10, 13 years, and we can see what early predictors were there that predicted who would be satisfied and stable in their relationships. So there's also good studies that show how to interact or how to resolve conflict.
那婚姻呢？我们抛开约会，当我们终于遇到某人，我们很幸福。心理学研究如何帮助确定是什么造就了持久幸福的婚姻？不仅仅是持久的婚姻，而是幸福的婚姻。幸福和长久两者兼顾。对，没错。嗯，现在有很多好的数据，我们很幸运有这些前瞻性研究，有时在人们遇到伴侣之前，有时在他们约会时，或者有时在他们刚结婚时就捕捉到他们，并跟踪他们七年、十年、十三年，我们可以看到哪些早期预测因素预示了谁会在关系中感到满足和稳定。此外，还有很好的研究展示了如何互动或如何解决冲突。
in a marriage and I think that's very valuable of course but if you want to go back and get it right as early as possible you'd say choosing somebody with certain traits or characteristics which are strong predictors of long-term satisfaction stability would probably be the best way to go what sort of things can couples do to sort of enhance their chances of being happy ever after sure well one example we give and the science of happily ever after is personality traits. And personality is great because it's really how we just describe who people are. And so it's a nice, intuitive, native kind of thing that we can discern with a good amount of accuracy if we're not falling in love with somebody. So that's the trick. And the good news about that
在婚姻中，我认为这当然非常有价值，但如果你想回到源头，尽早做对，你会说选择那些具有某些特质或特征的人，这些是长期满意度和稳定性的强预测指标，这可能是最好的方法。夫妻可以做些什么来提高他们获得幸福结局的机会呢？当然，我们在《幸福的科学》中给出的一个例子是性格特征。性格很棒，因为它确实是我们描述人是谁的方式。所以，这是一种很好的、直观的、天生的东西，如果我们没有陷入爱河，我们就能相当准确地辨别出来。所以这就是诀窍。关于这一点的好消息是
is your friends and family are pretty good judges of personality traits of your partner. Or people they don't know that well, they can pick up on personality traits pretty accurately in a relatively short amount of time. And so you take something like agreeableness or kindness, for example, that's a great predictor of long-term stability and satisfaction. So you should give your partner a personality test before you. Ideally, if you could slip them one and get some, you know, it brings up another good point about strategic self-presentation. And so partners are on their best behavior early on. And that's one of the nice things about observer ratings is that people's personality does tend to come out, even though they're trying to strategically self-present.
你的朋友和家人是伴侣性格特征的很好的评判者。或者对于他们不太了解的人，他们也能在相对较短的时间内相当准确地捕捉到性格特征。所以，以随和或善良为例，这是长期稳定和满意度的极好预测指标。所以你应该在结婚前给你的伴侣做一个性格测试吗？理想情况下，如果你能悄悄给他们做一个并得到一些结果，嗯，这引出了关于战略性自我呈现的另一个好观点。伴侣在早期会表现出最好的一面。而观察者评分的好处之一就是，即使人们试图进行战略性自我呈现，他们的性格也往往会显露出来。
And if you get an average or an aggregate of those observations, you can then use that with some of the knowledge we have to predict who would be a good partner on average and who wouldn't. What can people learn from failed relationships? As you said, you're in between your relationships, you're looking back, you know, why do people continue to make the same mistakes over and over again? Well, that was one of the first questions I had in grad school, actually. And so I was studying stress-related growth with Pat Frazier, and I thought, boy, these breakups and divorces are pretty stressful, and it's correlated with all kinds of psychopathology, like depression and anxiety disorders, substance use disorders. And most of the research on breakups has looked at some of those negative
如果你得到这些观察结果的平均值或总和，你就可以利用我们所掌握的知识来预测谁平均而言会是一个好伴侣，谁不会。人们能从失败的感情中学到什么？正如你所说，当你处于两段感情之间，你在回顾过去，为什么人们会不断地重复犯同样的错误？嗯，这实际上是我在研究生院时的第一个问题。当时我正在和帕特·弗雷泽（Pat Frazier）一起研究压力相关的成长，我想，天哪，这些分手和离婚压力很大，而且它与各种心理病理学相关，比如抑郁症、焦虑症、物质使用障碍。而大多数关于分手的研究都着眼于那些负面
outcomes. But there's a handful of studies that look at, well, what do people learn? Or what do people benefit from when they break up with somebody? And we found that every single person, in all these studies will say that they learn things or had certain growth or benefits from the breakup. The second question then is do they actually follow through then on these things? So if they say they're going to choose a better partner, let's say, for example, who's less neurotic, do they actually then choose somebody who's less neurotic in the next relationship? And I think the jury's still out as far as what the data is and what the findings will be about who experiences real growth versus people that maybe are just experiencing positive.
结果。但也有少数研究着眼于，人们学到了什么？或者当他们与某人分手时，他们从中获得了什么好处？我们发现，在所有这些研究中，每个人都会说他们学到了东西，或者从分手中有某种成长或收获。第二个问题是，他们是否真的在这些事情上付诸行动了？所以，如果他们说他们会选择一个更好的伴侣，比如，选择一个神经质程度较低的人，那么在下一段感情中，他们真的会选择一个神经质程度较低的人吗？我认为关于数据是什么以及关于谁经历了真正的成长，而谁可能只是经历了积极的感受，结论尚无定论。
they think they've grown but actually won't engage in the behavior that's congruent with that. So you really have to stop and look at, consciously really look, not only look at why maybe it didn't work out with that person, but you have to, like you said, develop a strategy moving forward to find the next person that you think would be the workout, let's say. Exactly. So I think you can borrow from some of the behavioral therapy components and say, well, what would be a tangible or observable marker that I would know that I've actually
他们认为自己成长了，但实际上并不会采取与此相符的行为。所以你真的必须停下来审视，有意识地审视，不仅要看为什么和那个人没有结果，而且你必须像你所说的那样，制定一个前进的策略，去寻找下一个你认为会成功的人。没错。所以我认为你可以借鉴一些行为疗法的成分，问自己，有什么具体的或可观察的标志能让我知道我实际上
done a better job. I had a client who had a great kind of concrete example, and she said that she kept dating bass guitarists in bands. And this tend to be correlated with sensation-seeking, really high-sensation-seeking, which led to a lot of bad decisions. So, you know, one of her markers was, does he play bass guitar in a band?
做得更好了。我有一个客户，她有一个很好的具体例子，她说她一直在和乐队里的贝斯手约会。这往往与寻求刺激有关，是非常高强度的寻求刺激，导致了很多糟糕的决定。所以，嗯，她的一个标志是，他是否在乐队里弹贝斯？
If he did, then she said, well, then I haven't met my criteria. All right. Okay, well, Dr. Tashiro, this has been very very. Very interesting. Thank you so much for taking the time to speak with us. Well, thanks for having me on. For more information, please visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Andrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果他弹，那么她说，好吧，那我就没达到我的标准。好的。好的，田代博士，这非常非常有趣。非常感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈。嗯，谢谢邀请我。欲了解更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《谈谈心理学》节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。